today on the matt wall show chaos in dc
yesterday as a group of trump supporters
stormed the capitol building i want to
talk about what led up
to those events the media and the left
for months were openly justifying and
encouraging riots and political violence
violence today they say that none of
that had anything to do with the riot in
dc but i think there's a very obvious
connection which we'll discuss today
also five headlines including
more on the mother and military veteran
who was shot and killed by capitol
police during the riot and president
trump
is suspended from twitter plus our daily
cancellation and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it's really impossible to
overemphasize the importance of
protecting your online data
you know if you're going to be online as
we all are uh you have to realize
that your data is susceptible to being
stolen and your identity sustainably
stolen that's why you have to protect
yourself and that's where lifelock comes
in
you know sensitive personal medical data
could be exposed as a recent analysis
suggests an increase in cyber security
attacks on pharmaceutical workers
the increase in remote work from home
has coincided with the targeting of
smartphones and tablets of people
working in pharmaceuticals with phishing
and malware attacks
that's why it's just important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft
are affecting our lives every day we put
our information at risk on the internet
and cyber criminals around the world
they keep finding new ways to steal your
information they're always
always innovating new ways to um
to cause you a lot of trouble basically
and that's why you need life luck
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale on the
dark web
and if they find out that something like
that is happening they're gonna they're
gonna immediately send you an alert and
god forbid if you do have a problem
they've also got specialists on the
staff who can help you
restore your identity and get things
back to where they need to be
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock can see threats
that you might miss on your own join now
and save
25 off your first year go to
lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off it is being demanded that we view
yesterday's events in dc as if they
occurred without precedent
nothing of importance or relevance
preceding them
right-wing trump supporters stormed the
capitol building vandalized fought with
police rain down
anarchy and there was no catalyst for
any of it no
underlying reason other than donald
trump and his incitements
this is how we're meant to see it but
i think it's important that we learn
from our experiences in this country
especially when those experiences are
horrendous and disgraceful as they were
in this case
and learning means understanding which
often means stepping back
and taking a wider view and we don't
need to widen the lens very much to see
that the rioting and violence on capitol
hill this week happened to occur after
many months of violent riots across the
nation violent riots which
were defended even romanticized
by many prominent voices in the media
and government now i'll be accused of
what about ism for refusing to pretend
that this particular bit of chaos
erupted in a in a void
in a vacuum utterly disconnected from
all that came before it
but that's not true the simple fact is
that left-wing radicals spent the entire
summer in much of the fall wreaking
havoc in our cities and leaving
burned-out buildings
looted stores dead bodies in their wake
they did this in dc as well multiple
times in fact over the summer in the
aerial shots of the of the city
after their protests looked like
something out of baghdad in 2003.
go look for yourself now it's being
argued that
the blm riots were a different sort of
thing because for one
the rioters were not fueled by
conspiracy theories but by valid
concerns over police brutality
also as the argument goes they were
targeting private businesses and not
government buildings so it's a
completely different thing
and uh and not nearly as bad
both of these arguments are of course
completely wrong on every level
now i'm not convinced that any writers
whether the ones this summer or the ones
in the capital yesterday
are actually motivated by anything other
than a savage desire to destroy purely
for the thrill of destruction
that's why i oppose writing in all its
forms all the time
it's illegal and destructive number one
but also it's fundamentally nihilistic
and i oppose nihilism but to whatever
extent the blm and antifa mobs were
animated by
outrage over police shootings they were
in almost every case
wildly wrong about the facts surrounding
those police shootings
indeed they'd been whipped into a frenzy
by falsehoods and conspiracy theories
just as outrageous as anything you may
hear in the q and on fever swamps
many of the police shootings that have
provoked rioting over the past several
months and years
were based on you know based on all
available evidence were completely
justified
that's just the fact we talked about
jacob blake yesterday
one example in fact this all began or at
least blm rose to prominence on the back
of the michael brown shooting
hands up don't shoot completely false
debunked
the movement was born in that falsehood
so it's not as though blm and antifa
have truth on their side far from it
what about their chosen targets again
it's not true that they victimized
only private businesses rioters
infiltrated and torched police stations
in minneapolis and portland and we hear
about
uh yesterday was a dark day it was
unprecedented
i agree but i think it's also pretty
unprecedented and i felt pretty shocked
i don't know about you
when i saw people infiltrating police
stations and burning them to the ground
in the middle of american cities
you want to talk about living in a third
world country
the federal courthouse in portland was
under sustained violent attack for weeks
add in all the police cars that were
incinerated or demolished by the mob and
the claim that yesterday was
unprecedented because it was an attack
on government property
reveals itself to be entirely absurd
but is it really worse to attack
government property anyway
yeah i'm not sure i agree with that
position
it's surely reprehensible to swarm the
capital and put our elected officials in
danger but
is it better to loot and burn a cvs or a
target and put the workers at those
establishments in danger
was it better when david dorn was
murdered for trying to defend his
friend's pawn shop from looters
is it is it really better
to burn down a convenience store because
you're mad that a violent felon was shot
by the cops is that better than swarming
the capital
can we not agree that all of these acts
are barbaric and untenable in a
civilized society
apparently we can't agree on that point
and that's exactly the problem
though we're supposed to erase all of
this from our mind now and pretend it
never happened the truth again
is that the media and the democrat party
spent much of the previous year offering
full-throated defenses of rioting and
looting and political terrorism
the very same people who are now shaking
their heads and muttering tearfully
about how the mob violence at dc
yesterday was a dark and unprecedented
moment in american history
were not but a few weeks ago openly
defending and encouraging mob violence
recall chris cuomo back in june i'll
play this clip for you just to jog your
memory
laughing at the very idea that protests
should be peaceful listen
to many see the protests as the problem
no the problem is what forced your
fellow citizens
to take to the streets persistent and
poisonous
inequities and injustice and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful well and as many people
pointed out to chris coleman of the time
it says that actually in
the first amendment but there was that
many things like it remember and also
remember celebrities like trevor noah
reclining thoughtfully in their mansions
and pontificating about how sometimes
protests
have to involve violence violence in
ours and it's necessary
here he is when you are have and when
you are have not
you see the world in very different ways
and a lot of the time people say to the
have-nots
this is not the right way to handle
things
when colin kaepernick kneels they say
this is not the right way to protest
when martin luther king had children
as part of his protests in birmingham
alabama people said
having children as your protest is not
the right way to do things when he
marched in selma
people said this is not the right way to
do things
when people marched through the streets
in south africa during apartheid they
said this is not the right way to do
things when people burn things they say
it's not the
it's never the right way because there's
never there is never a right way to
protest and i've said this before there
is no right way to protest because
that's what protest is
it cannot be right because you are
protesting against a thing that is
stopping you
that's what protest is and then many blm
leaders like the president of the
greater new york black lives matter
in this interview with tommy laron
declaring that rioting is the language
of the unheard
and that it is a tool of white supremacy
to insist on peaceful protests listen to
this
but you don't say anything against them
no but how you don't say that you know
what
because a riot is the language of the
unheard
right and for a country that drops bombs
on people
for a country that that incarcerates
people
for a country that enslaves people
to criticize us right
for for vandalism it's preposterous
i want to make sure i'm getting you
clearly it is okay
to vandalize to light things on fire and
to loot businesses
because the united states of america
drops bombs on other countries and
because we have
problems as problems here and we have
grievances people have grievances it is
okay to act in that manner and you
co-sign on to that as the chairman of
black lives matter
you were saying that that is okay let me
explain something to you
i think that it is a tool
of white supremacy to say if you want
what you get
if you want freedom then you get it by
protesting
peacefully why is it a tool of white
supremacy because
the white supremacists who built this
country never earned
anything peacefully they did it through
bullets
and blood bullets and blood do you
remember anyone on the left anyone in
the media
anyone among any democrats at all
condemning that
when he said it do you recall that
because i don't
far from it in fact democratic leaders
like alexandria casa cortez
insisted that to call for peace is to
call for injustice to continue listen
if you're trying to call for the end of
unrest but you don't believe health care
is a human right
if you're afraid to say black lives
matter
if you don't if you're too scared
to call out police brutality then you
aren't asking for an end of unrest
you are asking for injustice to continue
and she wasn't the only member of the
squad openly saying there should be
unrest in the streets ayanna presley
said the same
they know what unrest in the streets is
and what it looks like it looks like
burning buildings and dead bodies
they know that and they called for it
directly
see there's a consequence to these words
there's a consequence to the decision by
powerful and influential people
to put on their pompoms and act as
cheerleaders for violent murderous mobs
the consequence is exactly the result
they desired
which is the normalization of rioting
and the mainstreaming of political
violence
that was their endgame and now it's here
and now they want to
wash the blood from their hands and
preach about the need for civility
and those of us who object to this
charade
and call it what it is are accused of
what about
ism i'm not interested
in justifying anything that happened at
the capitol on wednesday
i'm even less interested in allowing the
cretans who set the stage for it
by encouraging that sort of behavior for
months on end
to now pretend they bear no blame this
is not just a matter of accountability
though it is that as well
it's a matter of understanding what's
happening in this country
in its full context and why it's
happening
because if there's any chance of
changing it now of pulling ourselves
back from the brink
we have to unders we have to start by
understanding where we are
and how we got here and that's how
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well staying on the events in the
capital uh one narrative we're hearing
from the left is that the cops went much
easier on protesters yesterday than they
have on blm and antifa
um and they went easier you know for
because they're racist right
here's joy reid on msnbc making that
case
and claiming outright that the rioters
yesterday were treated with kid gloves
because they're white that's what she
had to say listen it looked like a war
zone
police brought in tanks they brought in
body armor they were wearing full body
armor rubber suits where they almost
looked robotic
full gear enormous powerful weaponry
and they were phalanxed out all across
baltimore panning north they were
standing
menacingly waiting to brutalize anyone
who
even looked at them funny the level of
force the level of just almost
indiscriminate
rudeness cruelty hardness
of those police officers and at curfew
time which would be nine o'clock
and then almost every night during that
uprising
at some point i would go on with you
rachel and describe to you what i was
seeing
and it was terrifying and what terrified
me in those moments
in baltimore were not the marchers i was
never afraid among the marchers the
marchers
just wanted justice they just didn't
think it was okay to just kill a guy
because he looked at the police funny i
was afraid of them
i was afraid of the cops because they
were menacing
they knew those marchers were coming
every night they knew there was going to
be a curfew every night the great elijah
cummings would walk people home and get
them to go home because he didn't want
them out after curfew but there would
always be some guys who would stay out
after the curfew
who would refuse to go home who would
claim the right to be in their streets
and i was never afraid of them
i was afraid of the cops white americans
are never afraid of the cops even when
they're committing
insurrection uh
yeah that's and we've heard a lot of of
this kind of thing that well they
they went easy on on these uh protesters
uh because they're white and you know
look at with blm they came down to a
heartbeat
this is just total absolute nonsense
that we're expected to
accept we're expected to just accept it
and pretend that we haven't witnessed
what
we've witnessed over the last six months
it's not even though there's two years
of separation and they want us to
pretend that we didn't we don't remember
what happened two years ago even though
there were blm riots
happening two years ago too we're
talking about what what just
happened in this country what we all
spent all summer
watching and now they want to pretend
like none of it ever happened or just
rewrite the history of it
in front of our eyes that is nonsense
well as soon as blm shows up the cops
come down hard on them are you kidding
me
you idiot you liar
the cops stood back and let blm riot for
weeks look what happened in kenosha
days on end they were allowed to do it
we saw the videos of people just
strolling into targets
and cvs's and taking whatever they want
and walking out
we all saw that in cities across the
country
for weeks you lying snake
we all saw it so no no actually when blm
shows up
that's when the cops sit on their hands
because they don't want to be accused of
racism
that's the reality we've all seen it
we're just going to pretend we didn't
you can go on right now if
you're curious just go to google you can
find loads of videos of people just
setting things on fire strolling in
taking what they want assaulting
pedestrians
there's a there's a video i forget which
city was it might have been in new york
somebody runs up and
bashes a cop over the head with a brick
nothing happens to that guy on the video
he's not shot for it
bashes a cop over there with a brick
almost kills him there's multiple videos
of that
so that is total nonsense it's
especially nonsense when you consider
that the cops yesterday killed somebody
they shot one of these people and killed
them
a woman yesterday ashley babbitt mother
military veteran 14-year veteran
um went to the the protest she was at
the capitol
she was in the capitol building and i'm
you've probably seen the video i'm not
going to play it here if you haven't
this is extremely upsetting i mean
you're watching somebody die right in
front of you but
she tries to climb over a broken door
she's unarmed and they shoot her and
kill her okay that's what
so you're telling us that that's that's
going easy on them
to shoot and kill them no here's here's
what we know
here's what we actually know is the
truth
if that was a blm protest and that was a
black woman rather than a white woman
the outrage today from the media would
be
nuclear i'm telling you if it was the
exact
same situation exact same
but they're they're carrying blm flags
and she's
black instead of white the outrage today
would be like i don't think anything
you've ever seen
we all know that and there'd be more
rioting in in in response to it
instead is there any outrage nobody
cares media doesn't care
if anything they're justifying it openly
they're they're celebrating it
you look at what some leftists on
twitter are saying about it they're
happy it happened
so that's the truth and i'm just not
going to sit here and be lied to i'm
sorry
because the game we're supposed to play
as conservatives you know what we're
supposed to do today what the media
tells us we're supposed to do today
is uh just you know someone like myself
let's
sit in front of the camera and say i
condemn what happened yesterday
i condemn it unequivocally and that's
all i have to say i just condemn it it's
the worst thing that's ever happened in
the country
and uh nobody is to blame at all for it
except the people doing it
nothing led up to it we can't talk about
anything else we're just gonna talk
about how bad this one thing was
i'm not playing that game because that's
a lie
and i'm i'm not doing it
all right number two from the daily wire
uh says twitter suspended president
trump
president donald trump's account late on
wednesday evening for allegedly
violating
the site's terms of service multiple
times in response to the rights that
broke out washington dc
twitter safety reported as a result of
the unprecedented ongoing violence
situation in washington dc we have
required the
removal of three donald trump tweets
that were posted earlier today for
repeated and severe violations of our
civic integrity policy this means that
the account of donald trump will be
locked for 12 hours following the
removal of these tweets
if the tweets are not removed the
account will will remain locked
yeah so now
he's still the president so they're not
gonna i don't think they're gonna ban
him from twitter yet
but you could be sure they're going to
uh he's he
he's as good as finished as far as
twitter goes they'll restore his account
probably today at some point if they
haven't already
um but january 21st he's done they're
kicking him off
and i think that's now and and yes
there's a there's a
an egregious double standard there as
well because as i as we
have just gone through all these
examples many democrats
have been openly encouraging violence uh
doing it in public doing it on tv but
also doing it on twitter
i mean i can sit here and dig up some
aoc tweets i'm sure that uh
are in that vein and they don't get shut
down
right so there's the double standard
there but also i have to tell you and
maybe it's just because i'm in a
i'm in just in a bad mood today if you
can't tell um
i i i it's hard for me to feel much
sympathy for donald trump here on this
um it's hard for me to care if he gets
kicked off twitter
because trump had four years to do
something
about twitter to do something about
social media censorship social media
bias
and he didn't do anything that's that's
the truth he tweeted about it but you
know as with so many other things trump
tweeted about it and said he was very
angry and he cared about it but uh
at the end they didn't actually do
anything about it
and so he's going to face consequences
for that and they're going to kick them
off because they can
um all right number three
let's see from the daily wire it says
the washington post has issued a major
correction admitting that jacob blake
the kenosha wisconsin man shot by police
in august had in fact been
armed at the time the post on tuesday we
talked about this yesterday claimed that
in a tweet that police officers won't be
charged in shooting of jacob lake
an unarmed black man it was shot seven
times in the back and kenosha wisconsin
the article itself claimed blake was
unarmed when he was shot
but the kenosha d.a we played the the
audio for you
debunked that claim at a press
conference he said it was
incontrovertible that blake was armed
and uh video footage
proves in fact he he he said that jacob
blake admits that he was armed
jacob blake comes out and says yeah i
was armed
and still the media for months insisted
that no no you weren't
no you were you were unarmed um
after claiming was blake was unarmed the
post updated its article with a
correction at the top that reads
an earlier version of the story
incorrectly described jacob blake as
unarmed while his family has said he was
not armed when shot by police
prosecutors on tuesday said video
evidence depicts it depicts him
holding a knife the story has been
corrected
uh yeah they they they all just to be
clear they only corrected this because
they absolutely had to
because of the backlash they were
getting but if it wasn't for the
backlash they of course would keep that
falsehood up there
because they knew it was false when they
published it to begin with it's not like
it was a mistake they knew it was full
even before the press conference it was
it was known to everybody with
eyes that jacob lake was armed because
you could see it in the video you could
see him holding a knife
and you can hear them shouting drop the
knife so if you have eyes and ears
you knew he was armed and they knew it
so this is a retraction
because they were caught
that's all it is and when you see here
they they say well his family still says
that he was uh he was not armed
and this also shows something that
i guess people are often uncomfortable
pointing it out but it's the reality
that
oftentimes in these situations with
these police shootings
these high-profile police shootings um
oftentimes the families will just
straight up
lie about what happened
and that's a problem now you might say
okay well of course they're biased in
favor of their family member
okay i still say that doesn't excuse you
for lying especially when your lies are
fueling
uh rioting and and violence and murder
as it did in kenosha but
either way um the problem is that
whatever the family says
the media will treat the family
of this so-called victim as the ultimate
authority
and they'll just repeat whatever the
family says as if it's fact
but so often it is just not fact at all
they're lying
and if the family here is saying he
wasn't armed they are lying about that
um number four i wanted to play this for
you not to belabor the point but we were
talking about the media's encouragement
of writing
and i played a few examples for you but
this i just saw before we went on the
air here tom elliott at grabian media
put together i think it's a pretty
powerful i i didn't even show you the
half of it this is a pretty powerful
90-second compilation that i just want
to play for you just just
just to show you it says the media's
history of supporting antifa it's just
from
most of this is from the last the past
few months
and here's what it sounds like i argue
to you tonight
all punches are not equal
morally in the eyes of the law yes
but in the eyes of good and evil here's
the argument
they are strictly principled
anti-fascists
and what they see in the trump
administration and what they see
happening in this country
they see they see the neo-fascism that
we see
and they've taken a principle stand to
stand against white supremacists and
white nationalists wherever they may
show up
it says it right in the name antifa
anti-fascism which is what they were
there
listen there's you know no organization
is perfect there was some violence
i think that a lot of people recognize
that when pushed self-defense is a
legitimate response to white supremacist
and neo-nazi violence
the problem is to equate the violence in
reaction against bigotry
with the bigotry itself is to
misunderstand the fact that when you go
to cancer treatment
the radiation is tough treatment but it
is meant to remove the cancer
there's a group of anti-fascists called
the black bloc which do
tend to get violent their idea is look
non-violence hasn't worked and we
are going to try to stop this but they
wouldn't have been there they wouldn't
have been anywhere near there
had it not been for the fact that white
supremacists neo-nazis were out
scaring the living day loud out of most
of the people in that town sluggishness
is thuggishness
wherever it comes from politically and
we should be the first to call it out
i disagree i disagree
i know we shouldn't cut it we shouldn't
call out all thuggishness
not the kind that i like and that that
really is the difference i mean
if they're being honest uh the media
and they were to respond to the charge
of hypocrisy on this issue where they
were
openly supporting rioting for months and
now pretending to be
shocked and appalled by it um
and and violence and all that and their
honest answer is that
it it's okay when we do it that's it
it's it is it's okay when we do it and
if if
if they're doing it for a leftist cause
and especially if they're
if their victims are you know the have
the right uh
ideology and skin color than
right in terms of right for for being
the victim
then it's okay that's their answer
that's really what they believe that's
that's i guess the advantage of being a
moral relativist
that you don't have to hold yourself to
any standard at all
something can be totally wrong
when one person does it and totally okay
when someone else
does it because there is no
moral there is no objective moral truth
there is no universal
moral standard that everybody is held to
and that's what we're seeing here
all right five finally big celebrity
news from cnn here it is
kim kardashian west and kanye west are
figuring out their future and whether
they're going to stay married according
to two sources
close to kardashian west who spoke to
cnn the sources confirmed that west has
been living at their home in wyoming in
recent months
while his wife stayed in california with
their children they've been living
separately for the last few months
they've been in marriage counseling and
have discussed divorce
and sorry as i read as i'm reading this
i'm just realizing how little i care
i'm realizing that i don't care at all
about this story
um but there it is
they're getting divorced i it's it's
it's too bad and
and hopefully they'll they'll work out
their differences
that's my full analysis on that
particular story i'll tell you one
problem that i have and it's a pretty
pretty significant problem especially i
find myself in ubers and
and taking you know car services places
a lot so i'm in i'm in the back of cars
and uh and that's what's a problem when
i because i get very carsick
and what you don't want to do is vomit
in an uber
and you also don't want to have to ask
them to pull over so that you can be
sick because that's also embarrassing
and that's why i use relief ban relief
ban is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically proven
to quickly relieve and effectively
prevent nausea and vomiting associated
with motion sickness anxiety migraine
hangover
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product is 100 drug-free
non-drowsy
provides all-natural relief with zero
side effects technology was originally
developed over 20 years ago in hospitals
to relieve nausea
from patients but now through relief
band it's available to the masses relief
ben is the only
over-the-counter wearable device that's
been used in hospitals and oncology
clinics to treat nausea and vomiting
uh and the other great thing in my
experience my daughter also uses one
is that you know you can you can stop
and get uh you know they
have medicine for for motion sickness
but a lot of that a lot of stuff will
make you drowsy if you have to drive
or even if you don't have to drive but
if you got to be awake for the rest of
the day
then you don't want to be drowsy and
that's where a relief band again comes
in handy this new year ensure nausea is
never the reason to miss out on life's
important moments
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer just for matt walsh listeners if
you go to reliefband.com use promo code
walsh to receive 20
off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20
off uh also one other thing to mention
you know there's a reason why the media
creates narratives about conservatives
and has less to do with politics has
more to do with culture
which is which is shaped by the content
we consume that's
that's where like i've talked about
that's the real
that's gonna be the real influential and
uh and harmful bias
even more than in the news media it's in
the entertainment that we consume
the left has put media and entertainment
in a vice grip and it's time now to take
it back daily wire is releasing its
first feature film
we're very excited about it run hide
fight on friday january 15th for daily
wire members you can check out the
trailer
at the daily wire youtube go there now
check it out now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel gretchen
whitmer the empress of michigan who has
driven many of her citizens into
financial ruin over the past many months
but that's not why we're canceling her
now
she's being canceled for this tweet this
is from yesterday morning she says
good morning no problem there
um not really anyway and but there's a
photo of a prayer candle adorned with
the image of stacey abrams
abrams is wearing a robe holding a bible
has a halo around her head
this is not the only example of
religious worship being directed at
stacey abrams who many on the left
credit with
helping to mobilize support for the
democrat candidates in georgia which
ultimately won them the state in the
senate
and that's why they're being especially
worshipful towards her today
actor mark ruffalo also tweeted a
picture of abrams along with the caption
stacey abrams is a real super superhero
once again
saving us all and as noted by the hill
says quote
comedian chelsea handler and frozen
songwriter chris songwriter kristen
anderson lopez suggested statues should
be erected in abramson's honor
and west wing alum uh richard schiff
floated making her person of the year
while actress rosanna arquette
predicted the fair fight action founder
would be the recipient of the country's
highest civilian honor
also cher said that abrams is a goddess
but topping them all is a tweet from a
guy named jeff tedrick
saying quote i want to bear stacey
abramson's
children he wants to bear her children
which i'm told these days is possible
somehow
but just so you know if anyone ever asks
you for the definition of the term
beta male just show them that tweet
that's uh
that's it right there the personality
cult around stacey abrams is i have to
say
one of the absolute weirdest things in
american politics
which is saying quite a lot these days
especially she is not charismatic or
especially impressive or accomplished
she's a mediocre failed politician much
like camila harris who's also now lauded
as a deity in her own right which we
discussed
earlier in the week but i suppose we
should expect
the stacey abrams personality cult to be
weird because they're all weird
all the personality cults and so on
second thought i'm canceling all
personality cults of all kinds
especially those
that form around politicians or in this
case
would be politicians now it's one thing
to support a politician
even to like a politician personally i
tend to dislike all of them by default
and then at best i'll develop a mild
tolerance
for the ones that disgust me the least
that's that's pretty much as far
as i go you can ask me which politicians
do i like i can't really tell you that i
can tell you which ones disgust me the
least
which am i least repulsed by that's
that's as far as i can go
i'm not suggesting that everybody should
be as cynical as me but if not cynical
we should at least be skeptical of
politicians we should always keep in
mind
that they're in a position of power over
people
and that they wanted that position
that's why they're there
you know it now it could be that they
wanted it because they have such a deep
and abiding passion for public service
maybe that may be the case for like
four or five politicians in the history
of america
the rest though you know they may have
some degree of passion for public
service but
the fact is that there's also a fair
amount of narcissism greed self-interest
and so on
that propels their drive to power i mean
you just have to think about
what is it that would make you want
to be have power and control over people
why would you go through all this just
so you could be in this position
again you might have noble reasons but
most of the time for most people you
don't
now as you know i plan to one day be the
theocratic dictator of america and it's
entirely greed to narcissism that fuels
that desire for me so
i know what i'm talking about here the
point is that the only safe and prudent
and truly american attitude towards
politicians is one of cautious
skepticism support them when they're
right criticize them when they're wrong
and never expect them to be your savior
or your goddess or your god
this is one of the great problems we
face in american society today i think
in my view
even if people are not literally putting
halos around a politician and lighting
prayer candles with her face on it
still many americans have been
conditioned to look to politicians
especially politicians on the national
stage
for the answers to their problems you
know we're searching for someone to save
us to restore
our hopes and dreams and everything but
that is not something a politician can
do
and the one the ones that promise they
can do it are always lying
and they all promise they can do it so
what does that tell you
if america is to be saved whatever that
means exactly
it will happen in your home in your
family
and in everybody else's mother teresa
famously said if you want to change the
world
go home and love your family it sounds
like a platitude but there's a deep
truth in it
and it's much better than if you want to
change the world
go vote for this problem this person who
will solve all your problems
that's a cultish mentality and it's
part of what's destroying us right now
which
is why it is canceled
but again especially the cult around
stacey abrams because that one is just
her of all people i mean at least choose
someone who's charismatic
at least then you can sort of understand
it but stacy
abrams come on canceled cancelled
canceled down the board
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo valdoski
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
we'll tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there